okay well this is a girl whatever let's
do it
hey guys hey what's your name okay uh
how much you supposed to tolerate in a
relationship you know relationship like
Bobby a lot
my boyfriend plays way too much
videogames he's awful with money which
stresses me out and often puts me a
position of being the stable bank even
though I'm self-employed and had myself
to take care for okay unfair he smokes
weed everyday all the time let me just
say this to you before um now I'm gonna
even let you finish okay I love your
shows
I'm not even let you finish okay kalila
loves kalila loves the ocean did you
know that immensely people she loves the
water
she loves the beach she loves um
swimming with you know sea creatures and
she just likes being in nature hmm this
would hurt me if kalila said this it
would hurt me if Clara said hey man I'm
gonna just go to Hawaii for a year and
live on the beach mm-hmm I'm like I'm
gonna miss you so much but please and
I'd let it go and if he wants to play
video games if you love him that's what
he loves to do let him [ __ ] do it and
not if he's smoking weed all day and not
getting okay working if he wants to
smoke weed which is what he loves to do
and play video games is what he loves to
do and you love him right
you should support what he loves and if
you don't love him leave find somebody
else
fine you know I'm Michael Phelps who
wins championships for who same boat who
runs circles around others but my point
is is this you might not have the right
guy what do you think of that all right
because it doesn't matter if my
girlfriend smoke pot and and play video
games all day long and that's what she
loved to do by all means do it I think
that Bobby's right
good one fine an Olympian I'd let them
do whatever they want their lives I
think that if he is somebody who was I
just hear the rest of it so you mate you
have a better yeah I think I can kind of
get what she thinks right let me finish
it so his tolerance is high he he smokes
weed every day all the time his
tolerance is high though so he does it
doesn't show he says it helps us anxiety
I accept the medical reason but I don't
accept weed being prioritized even when
money is low
he has been off it and has been just
fine I also feel the weed might be a
reason for his extremely low work ethic
lack of ambition of life generally and
comfortability of rarely even suggesting
fun things to do outside of the house
but that's what I'm saying like he
sounds like a deadbeat Bobby plays video
games every day but he goes to work and
he brings home the bacon so unless he's
doing that he should not be allowed to
slide by like a [ __ ] slob and not
provide anything for the family
especially if he's you know I mean like
he's yeah he has to he has to pay rent
he has to provide food he's gonna do
those things yes it's the video game I
can't argue with his video game playing
because he goes to work he travels on
the road he has a career he is ambitious
hmm those so therefore video game play
is something that I just cannot complain
about because he's he's still getting
his [ __ ] done mmm
but this dude doesn't sound like he's
getting [ __ ] done so he drop his ass she
says now I ain't no [ __ ] but if it
wasn't for the fun times we have
together I would have left a long time
ago something you can have so many fun
times with so many different people why
don't you have fun times with somebody
who could actually enhance your life a
little bit more than this dude okay it's
a great actor all right okay so thanks I
fell upon your welcome he doesn't even
need a lot of money he just needs to
show some type even a little like a
morsel of ambition saying you know what
today I'll tell you the example I fly in
from Dallas mm-hmm
and then [ __ ] Adam Ray goes me and
the little man are doing a you said you
would do it I haven't slept I was gonna
sleep all day because I was gonna do
this podcast wouldn't he rest I'm like
[ __ ] I made a commitment it's a part of
my job mm-hmm I showed up I hung out
with those guys I did the podcast I came
here we set up for this I did this I
haven't played video game once all day
today because I have to do my business
first do you understand
everyone
[Music]